what got me through 2020 got me through
20 20. you got me through the year 2020
what do i say the thing that got me
through quarantine here's what got us
through 2020.
[Music]
tv shows that gave me something to look
forward to like little fires everywhere
insecure and i may destroy you love
craft country shit's creek
stevie is my soul mate starting real
housewives the real housewives of
potomac
watching tons of true crime documentary
and food documentaries
the great british baking show the return
of unsolved mysteries unsolved mysteries
on netflix was my jam i do appreciate a
good cult doc
i've enjoyed walking down memory lane
with shows like
half and half one on one the game
girlfriends the parkers queen's gambit
i've decided when i grow up i want to be
a chess champion in the 1960s a lot of
reality tv
we got dance moms we got tiger king
below deck below deck sailing yacht
below deck mediterranean emily in paris
and selling sunset all the new korean
dramas on netflix
minus startup rewatching gilmore girls
re-watching
30 rock parks and rec and brooklyn
nine-nine re-watching
avatar the last airbender for the fifth
time my nintendo switch
animal crossing animal crossing i built
the island of my dreams on animal
crossing
ring lights zoom face some of my friends
and my family
zooming with my friends weekly trivia
nights that i had with a group of my
friends and family tick tock
grandma's on tick tock food videos on
tik tok working
in my pjs my leggings from girlfriend
collective sitting all day at the
computer at home
you gotta make it comfy baby seat
cushion
future nostalgia by dua lipa ungodly
hour by chloe and holly
and positions by ariana grande lady
gaga's album
chromatica chromatica 2 transition memes
beyonce i taught myself how to play the
piano taylor swift's new album
folklore singing and dancing in my room
with the music
way too loud is something that has
helped me adam melcher playing music
live on instagram
adopting my new puppy my cat dogs
my rascal adopting a quarantine cat
adopting this beautiful one-eyed
english bulldog named sunny my new puppy
buying lots of plants anthony horowitz
murder mystery novels
all of the books that i was able to read
my 200
foldable exercise bike from amazon my
peloton
cycling late night bike rides at the
beach you can't beat that anyone for
tennis
chloe tang workouts i bought a brand new
bike the circles
in madison square park on the grass
baking
the johannes machine is one of the best
purchases i made in 2020.
cooking a lot this little pasta maker
was the best
purchase i had all year in 2020. so
much pasta lots and lots of ben and
jerry's
non-dairy ice cream hello fresh because
i'm a horrible cook and i had to start
cooking at home
ginger seltzer from whole foods trader
joe's trader joe's plantain chips
tequila the fact that so many people
left new york city and the rent went
down and i was able to afford a bigger
apartment so the only thing that keeps
me sane is superheroes
video games nba 2k 20 nba 2k 21 kyoto
sashima
cyberpunk 2077 and my friends my
roommate my boyfriend my family
my family my husband my girlfriend
my girlfriend in the summer being
outside with my parents
when we have like a little campfire
going and us drinking wine like
that's a memory that i now have because
i was able to spend this time with them
i got to eat dinner with my family for
thanksgiving even though i'm in
california and they're in florida
my parents set up the phone so that i
was seated where my normal seat would be
at the dinner table i
almost felt like i was there being able
to watch
this cutie grow
[Music]
you